hi everyone thank you so much for
attending my talk today
about cannabis laboratory testing
workflow from receipt to results
just a quick introduction of myself my
name is carly barone
and i am the chemistry lab manager
of a cannabis testing laboratory located
in
colchester vermont usa
just a quick overview of what we'll be
discussing today
we'll start with a brief introduction of
cannabis we'll go through
testing workflows starting from receipt
through processing
data analysis and reporting results and
then we'll finish by talking about some
challenges we face
in cannabis testing laboratories and how
we can move forward
one term i will be using throughout this
presentation
is cannabis and this includes both hemp
and marijuana
both belong to the genus cannabis and
can be described by three species
indica sativa and root oralis so what's
the main difference between the two
there are well there's some
morphological differences in the flower
basically it's a difference in the
amount of thc or chemical makeup of
those
plants and federally hemp is described
as being less than
0.3 percent delta 9 thc
based on dry weight
just a quick overview of the history of
cannabis cannabis actually dates back
about 6 000 years to 4000 bc in china
when it was actually used as a food crop
but today we will just be looking at the
past 50 or so years
starting in 1970 when cannabis was made
illegal
and classified as a schedule 1
controlled substance
in 1996 california was the first state
to legalize the medicinal use of
cannabis
and in 2014 president obama signed the
farm bill
allowing hemp to be cultivated for
research purposes
very recently the farm bill of 2018 was
passed
federally legalizing hemp and hemp
derived products
and today specifically where we are in
vermont
adult use and medicinal marijuana use
are legal
but the recreational sale of marijuana
is not legal as of yet
so there are countless matrices that
contain cbd and thc you name it there's
probably a product out there
we see anything from stock treats to
gummies to
bath products and all of which need to
be
treated treated specifically in our
laboratory
and not only do we see a lot of
different matrices
but cannabis itself is a very complex
matrix
cannabis actually contains 545 compounds
and 104 of those are cannabinoids
so while cannabis is an extremely
complex matrix and we see a whole slew
of different matrices in the laboratory
we also need to not only look at
cannabinoid
potency but we're looking at a list of
contaminants as well so
these include residual solvents terpene
profile
heavy metals pesticides microbials and
mycotoxins
with this long list of compounds we
really need laboratories that are able
to test
accurately and quickly and
[Music]
this is done using a workflow that is
efficient
and one that works for that laboratory
specifically
so the first part of the our workflow
starts with us receiving a sample
so the second the sample comes in they
are labeled with a unique
identification code or a barcode and the
corresponding information is entered
into our system
we want to make sure that we have the
customer information sample information
the tests that are requested by the
customer the sampling date and the
submission date
so here is an example of our sample
submission form in our laboratory
you can see on the top of the form we
have all the customer information
our sample is described below as well as
what
tests are requested for check boxes you
can see there
and also we are asking what the matrix
is of the
sample there's also billing information
on there for invoicing as well
so first things first when we receive a
sample once it's checked in
and put into our system we first want to
put these samples into categories
and this helps us move forward with our
process so
we can really
place things such as gummies oils and
chocolates into a low concentration
category we place our flowers into the
medium category
and then isolates and concentrates will
be described as high concentration
products
and no matter what the matrix is
everything is going to start by getting
homogenized
so this allows us to take a
representative homogenous sample of the
submitted product
and this can be done differently in
laboratories either using a grinder
liquid nitrogen stainless steel
agitators
or cryogrinder
so once the sample has been checked in
homogenized and weighed out based on
whatever test
we are testing for we are then going to
extract it so
even though we had categories where
chocolate and oil end up in the same
concentration category those are
actually going to be extracted
differently
so samples are extracted according to
the specific matrix
and as of right now laboratories are
doing this differently
so far aoac has approved an official
method for cannabinoids
and they're working on many others but
this is the only
official approved method so far
once everything is extracted and ready
to go we are ready for analysis
as i mentioned we analyze for
cannabinoids
terpenes residual solvents heavy metals
pesticides
mycotoxins and microbials and all of
these
are done differently we can have a
sample come in that is solely for
cannabinoid testing or we can have a
sample come in that
needs a full panel
so we'll first look at cannabinoids
in our laboratory we're testing
cannabinoids using high performance
liquid chromatography or hplc
and this can be tested with many
different methods
some laboratories are using gcms some
laboratories are using lcm sms
or other methods in our laboratory we're
looking at 12 main cannabinoids
and other laboratories will look for six
some will look for 16
depends on what the customers are
looking for and are interested in seeing
their products
we also are reporting total tac
in total cbd based on these numbers
and so federally we know that the action
limit for delta 9 thc
based on dry weight is 0.3 percent um
here in vermont vermont has actually set
a one percent limit on total thc
and then if we're looking at moisture
content which plays a role in all of our
analyses
we want our trim flower and this is all
specifically for hemp here
in vermont to be 13
moisture and 0.65 water activity
next is residual solvents residual
solvents are found when
a cannabis product
has been extracted using some type of
solvent
and this needs to be removed before the
customer actually ingests it so we're
testing to see if there's any solvents
that are left over we are using gas
chromatography
mass spec to do this because these
most of these compounds are pretty
volatile
and you can see the state of vermont has
set limits
for a list of residual solvents
that we do not want to see show up in
customer samples over these limits
using gcms we're also testing terpenes
because they're also volatile compounds
we're looking at 22 terpenes to include
limonene
pinene and caryethylene
while this is not one of the regulated
list of compounds by the state of
vermont um
it basically because it is not
associated with potency and is not
considered a contaminant either
we are still looking at these compounds
because customers are interested in
seeing their
terpene profile the importance of the
terpene profile for customers is that
not only does it give the aromatic
signature of that product but it also
has been shown to
contribute to the entourage effect and
have some
medicinal benefits
also looking at heavy metals for this we
are using icpms technology
and we are looking for four main metals
the importance of looking for heavy
metals is that the canvas plant is
actually really good at
uptaking heavy metals from the soil as
well as from any agricultural water used
so the state of vermont has set limits
for
action limits for flour as well as
a list of limits for concentrates
products and infused products
next we can look at pesticides we are
using liquid chromatography
dual mass spectrometry for this and
with this technology we are able to use
look at
60 different pesticides pesticides are
important because they are being used
in the hemp arena and the cannabis arena
just like they are in in most crops
and the state of vermont has a pre
comprehensive list here of
15 different pesticides um but i
you know that other states are actually
looking at you know 90 plus pesticides
so this is a rather short list compared
to those states
we are also looking at microbials
so we have a couple different
methodologies that we use
to look at these when looking at total
yeast in mold
and total aerobic bacteria these are
quantitative
methods used on plates you can use
petrofilm
and these are plate counts essentially
we are also looking at mycotoxins
we use lcm sms to do this
quantitatively and on the lcm sms we can
test for
aflatoxins a1a2 g1g2
as well as opertoxin a
there are also specific bacterias you
can test for
aspergillus which is actually a fungus
those different species can actually be
tested for
via pcr these are qualitative tests
usually
and the state of vermont has set limits
for microbials
we have different limits for trim flower
different limits for concentrates
and different for products and abuse
products
so once everything has been analyzed for
the requested tests
we do a final check on all parameters so
that's making sure that our blanks are
blank
it's making sure that our controls and
check standards
have come in at the correct
concentrations that we're expecting them
to
we want to make sure that our
calibrations are linear
and we also want to make sure that in
our chromatogram is spectra that our
peaks are showing up at the correct
times
and that they are being identified
correctly
if we have to double check we can always
use
nist to crop cross reference for some of
our testings
so once all the results have been
validated and approved
we can then move on to generating
reports and
this comes with a whole list of its own
approval and checklist
but once the report has been generated
and checked
we can then release that certificate of
analysis to the customer
one of the main points here for the
customer is to make sure that there are
explanations
so for example on our reports we have
a small box that gives it gives a
explanation of how total thc is
calculated how total cbd is calculated
how the percent moisture plays a role in
their results
and this is really important because
this is a fairly new industry we have
farmers that are new to the industry
and so sometimes that means a phone call
sometimes that means some supplemental
information for people
and just to make sure that they
understand that what their results mean
for their
product this is really important for
them because
the state of vermont has set limits for
what their results should be compared to
the label value that they're placing on
that product
one really great resource for cannabis
testing workflows
are lens software so limbs are really
great at data management
generating reports and keeping
everything really organized and flowing
smoothly
so there are lens systems out there that
are specific to cannabis laboratories
and will really keep your workflow
efficient and working correctly
so once everything has been generated
and given to the customer
billing and invoicing will be done and
then
we will store the sample for future use
or
disposal
so what are some challenges that we're
facing currently within the cannabis
testing workflow
one of the biggest ones is the lack of
data the lack of validation work done
there are stan few standard methods as i
mentioned
the aoac method for cannabinoids
is one of the only ones out there right
now
and um we are like i mentioned
the different number of matrices that
we're seeing
do pose a challenge in that
it definitely expands the number of
extractions
and then and the amount of work that is
done
during your workflow of processing
additionally um there are
big variances between laboratories and
this is probably due to the lack of
standardization
which is a huge problem so like i
mentioned a lot of laboratories are
using different
extraction methods different techniques
different
instrumentation to test for the same
things
this just causes variance and we see
that
um between laboratories and
as well as you can see variants in
sample prep so
um how the how the customer has sampled
the plant
um can cause some variances in in the
results that you're seeing
human error sampling size
and then also once again going back to
the fact that
cannabis is a very diverse matrix
and this is just making everything even
more challenging
so some things that we can do moving
forward as cannabis testing laboratories
aoac is a great organization
that is working really hard to
standardize
and create standardized methods for this
industry like i said
they have already put one method through
and they are actively working on many
more for contaminants as well
and if you're not familiar they have a
program called
casp casp which is which
they are working very hard on improving
the standardization of the cannabis
industry for testing
additionally a great resource for
laboratories
is becoming iso 17025
this is an accreditation body and a
regulatory body so essentially
making sure that all of your methods
are validated and you have a quality
control system in place
iso 17025 is great for laboratories
as well as for example in our state
we have a canvas quality control program
which is similar to iso
17025 and for our state
the regulatory body is the agency of
agriculture
and other states is different but this
is essentially the same idea
validating methods as well as
keeping a quality control system in
place
additionally moving forward
seeing more validation studies will
improve
either in our laboratory or
multi-laboratory studies
solidifying regulations as well as
more laboratories becoming iso
accredited as well as
certified laboratories within their
states
proficiency testing is another great
point to
touch on for laboratories this is great
for
making sure that your laboratory is
providing
accurate results it also allows you to
compare
with other laboratories and
just allows the laboratory to make sure
that they're doing things correctly
making sure you have a quality system in
place is really important for
laboratories as well as
standards and method development which
aac is doing a great job
pushing forward in this in this industry
and i think the most important part of
all of this
is the training education and outreach
for laboratories
and laboratory scientists and
technicians
and just making sure that everybody's on
the same page
working towards the same goals and like
i said
standardizing it so that we are all
producing
accurate quality data and
making sure that in between laboratories
things are able to come out looking the
same
and moving forward
basically as this industry grows we just
want to make sure we're growing with it
as a laboratory
too so making sure you're staying up to
date on
all the newest methods and staying up to
date
on how you can continually improve
your your laboratory workflow
is really important this is an
ever-changing thing
and we're always changing and improving
and making sure we're
we're growing with this industry
and feel free to email me
or ask any questions thank you so much
for joining me today